l'avis de vincent roy a complètement
changé en juin 2019
l'homme de 31 ans de saint-isidore a
appris qu'il souffrait d'une maladie
auto immune très rare ils m'ont
diagnostiqué un syndrome de good pachter
salle alphonse émises anticorps qui
attaquent miron enfin que j'étais
hospitalisée puis après plusieurs
semaines
j'ai arrêté d'uriné corps humain me
rends été rendu l'eau à 0 pour saint
vincent roy doit se rendre trois fois
par semaine à lévis pour faire de la
dialyse une routine épuisante qui
l'empêchent de mener une vie normale
c'est pas un remède miracle ça me
maintient en vie tant mais nos enfants
au monde c'est pas pour acquis une date
de fin avant nous
sans hésiter ses parents ont entamé les
démarches pour lui offrir un de leurs
reins la transplantation d'un donneur
vivant comparativement à 1 décédé permet
de diminuer les délais de deux ans à
neuf mois
mais la pandémie est venu bousculer les
plans un an et demi après le diagnostic
de leur fils ils ne savent toujours pas
s'ils sont compatibles et je m'agite
ceux là qui sont en attente d'un coeur
puis qui est certain c'est l'apocalypse
pour les autres parce que là c'est la
vie ou la mort lyon pas de deadline out
ou chutes québec on concède que la
pandémie a ralenti les démarches pour
certaines transplantation d'organes
particulièrement lorsqu'il s'agit de
donneurs vivants
on peut s'assurer que les gens qui font
le don d'un lorrain ils sont en parfaite
santé puis qui mettent pas leur propre
santé en jeu pour faire une seule greffe
on va devoir investir quatre personnes
c'est déjà complexe quand on n'est pas
en période de pandémie alors imaginez
avec la pandémie
le délestage qui s'est faite moins qu'un
jeantet le mot éclosion à tva que
j'entends un délestage c'est un moulin
elles l'aiment vraiment po disant
regarde les nombres de cas par jour puis
quand je vois que ça montre le sait ça
ça me fait de la peine ça me stresse
tout aussi vincent roy demande aux gens
de respecter des consignes sanitaires
afin de soulager le réseau de la santé
c'est ça achève bien nouille un vaccin
qui est arrivé en avoir d'autres marchés
puis on peut quand même se voir des
hommes le chute québec estime pouvoir
rattraper le retard pour les greffes de
rein
si la fin de l'été ici mark canton en
avoir radio-canada saint-isidore en
beauce